okay let's take the rest of the
discussion offline and
uh our last speaker for today is from
tti chicago
and he'll be telling us about stochastic
gradient descent with the friendship
right and this is worklet i'm sorry i'm
coming down with something so
and also i'm standing between you and
mine so uh i'll try to
try to go actually extra fast here um
okay so what i'm going to talk about
today is a stochastic gradient descent
and obviously differential privacy so
what what's going on here so
why do people like stochastic gradient
at the center of the stochastic
optimization methods
it's because if you have a lot of data
then doing standard
uh standard the computation uh
gradients is is challenging because it's
so hard to fit all the data on a single
machine or maybe your data is coming in
online in a streaming setting and
the delay may uh the data also might
come with constraints such as privacy
but also there's this computational
challenge uh where
like you just can't run the standard
algorithm because you have
too much data so the problem we're going
to consider is just a convex
minimization problem so i want to
minimize
some function of n data points z1
through zn uh i guess
maybe we should have had some notation
standardization at the beginning of the
workshop
probably i'm going to do something
completely different than everyone else
um
so what we want to do is minimize a sum
of some loss function over the data
points so w is the parameter i'm
optimizing over i want to find the best
w
say a d dimensional vector that
minimizes some loss over the data
and so uh if i wanted to minimize this
directly
uh essentially i'd have to and i would
do say gradient descent i'd have to
compute n gradients
uh one for each loss function uh which
is like taking one full scan over the
data which is
like not possible um in a lot of cases
um so as a concrete example i'm just
gonna look at logistic regression
because i like logistic regression
and in this case the uh data is just a
labeled pair so the x
is a vector d dimensional vector and y i
is a label
plus minus one label indicating you know
x is a data test values and y
is whether or not the person has a
disease um and what i'll do is minimize
this regularized uh logistic
uh i'll replace this loss function by
this logistic loss which is just a way
of weighting how
um wrong my predictor wt is on
on this uh uh on
this xt right thank you uh and uh
and then there's a there's this
regularization to prevent overfitting
right so this is like
standard uh machine learning stuff okay
so uh if so in in particular for those
who are not um
familiar because i know there's some non
um sort of computer scientists uh
engineering types here uh basically what
we're trying to find is a is a hyper
plane w defines a hyperplane which
separates my data into two classes
plus one and minus one right uh so we
often
solve this problem using gradient
descent but when n is very large we have
to compute ingredients as i said before
and it's
pretty uh pretty hairy so what do people
do
people do uh stochastic what's called
stochastic gradient descent so what i do
is i have my end data points and i just
pick one of them at random and i do a
gradient step with respect to that one
data point so that's
uh and i just operate iteratively so
this is
my estimate of the minimizer w star is
at time t plus one oops is forgot a bold
place uh
is um equal to my old estimate minus a
gradient step
um and this is the gradient of uh of the
previous
uh objective function just evaluated at
the one point and you have the
regularization there with the lambda
and this eta t is this uh constant a
multiplicative factor outside this is
the
called the learning rate sometimes or in
step size and we often set it to
something like one over t
or constant over t or constant over root
t those are pretty standard uh choices
um and so some things to note about this
is that the expected gradient if i took
the expect i'm taking a random data
point at each time the expected gradient
is a true gradient so this is really
just a stochastic approximation to the
standard gradient descent algorithm
um and so you can do your robins monroe
type thing
um in practice though uh what people do
is actually sample without replacement
so you just do a scan through the data
you know um just process each data at
one point at a time but the theoretical
guarantees are usually for the
sampling model um
and then uh often what you find in
practice is they take a few passes
through the data and then you're pretty
much good as good as you would do as if
you would process all the data
in full full-on gradient descent
so these are kind of the things that you
do in practice right and so
um what about privacy obviously so
if uh the data is private um
then you know you have to think about
the data actually as being kind of a
limited resource because every time i
touch a data point i'm going to pay a
epsilon for my differential privacy so
now it's not like i can just scan
through the data multiple times until
i'm done
you have to think about how you're going
to do that right so now i'm balancing
privacy and utility and somehow
efficiency of
of my computational procedure but maybe
it's easy because
essentially uh the stochastic gradient
descent is already a randomized
approximation to the regular gradient
descent so maybe i'm just adding some
more noise and that's
fine right okay so what do you do uh
this for the gradient set procedure it's
not
i mean i mean not this is not new news
uh you just add some noise to gradient
right so you
you now take a noisy gradient step and
you kind of hope that
the the fact that this is a noisy
approximation of the true gradient and
this is some more noise
what is the distribution of that noise
it's we're going to choose a
laplace-like isotropic and uh laplace
distributed
um and we're just going to add noise at
every um
at every iteration at every iteration
okay super i will be done before that
um and this guarantees differential
privacy in the continuous observation
setting which
which many people are probably familiar
with or more recently this also
satisfies in this local privacy model so
these are slightly different notions
um the point being here that i can
actually just publish the iterate
as i go along the whole path and so this
is like the continuous observation model
in the local privacy model the idea is
that i go to the data holder who holds
the data
z and i say please compute for me a
gradient and they say no i'm going to
give you this noisy gradient instead and
then then you
operate in that way so this is the
the the setting we're in and so okay so
why don't we just do it
what happens oh not so great um so here
i'm plotting uh
this is for synthetic data sets like
gaussians oh no sorry it's a uniform
distribution on the sphere
um and uh the standard algorithm
converts you can see it's like after a
thousand iterations
just without noise it's like i'm there
i'm done uh this is the value of the
objective function whereas uh
the differentially private algorithm not
only has pretty large variants it sort
of takes a long time to get there so you
you'd have to have a pretty large data
set if you're going to go a single scan
through the data set to get close to
um what you would get without
and privacy what is the and why yeah
it's even worse um
so what is the normalization of the data
and one private cigarette here should
you report
epsilon not delta alpha
the normalization of the data uh they're
the unit
you're rescheduling the item
and not every data item is a unit vector
yeah at most normal ones yeah okay yeah
so yeah maybe there's some
obviously pre-processing tricks to play
here yeah you seem to have started your
non-private algorithm at a much better
place than
maybe um
no no that's a zero that's your
objective value yes i mean
after zero iterations it's not no no
it's it's it's it's actually no it's
it's
this this is a zero this way and it's
like
it is descending um
no i'm not i'm not plotting the initial
i'm not approaching the initial value
i'm plotting the first
first published value yeah yeah yeah
sorry the
randomized the initialization was
randomized
right i'm not being super unfair it's
just
but it's back sizeable i mean so you
know it's just like okay so you can't
just like
you know uh it's not like you can do it
the day before the homework assignment
is due and then expect it to work right
okay this holds for other data sets as
well and mnist is apparently
particularly bad
so there are lots of knobs to tweak
though when you do any of the when you
implement any of these gradient descent
procedures you have lots of things to
play with
um you can first off play with the step
size just choosing the step size one
over t
or whatever and just letting it run is
actually usually not going to work well
in practice
um so it's kind of an art and so people
typically i was talking to the skype
event worker
and he was like yeah so what i do is i
just run it for one
you know one over two for like a
thousand steps and then one over three
four thousand steps and that usually
sort of works most most of the time but
that's like not science right
so um there's also an issue of the noise
level versus multiple passes i could
probably pay like
half of my epsilon and do two passes and
maybe that would be better because i
have more iterations
that's another there's also something
called polyjack averaging where i
average the iterates
that might also be better in fact it's
often quite
much much better in practice but what
i'm going to talk about here is mini
batching which is essentially just
processing multiple
points at once which also maybe is not
um
not too surprising so what do you do
with mini batching so now i'll just
sample
b points uniformly at random for the
data set and i'll take
average gradients to i'll compute b
gradients and then take a great uh step
that way
um and so with privacy i'm going to do
that but now i get a b factor reduction
in the in the noise so maybe
it's like everything will be much better
and notice i've just given up on the
local privacy model here because uh now
uh i can't ask this
i'm not i'm not i'm not asking for
points individually but it's still sort
of continuous observation
um so uh what do we
what do we hope here so if i make one
pass if i'm still going to consider
taking only one pass through the data
and so now we have a new trade-off so we
could either take very many gradients
many gradient steps which are very noisy
so like i'm really drunk and i'm trying
to drunkenly stop blowing my way through
the up to the optimum
or i could take fewer gradient steps
that are less noisy so i'm a little bit
uh more cautious but i
i take fewer minifigure steps and how
many fewer it's like that's one over b
times the number of steps so it's like
many fewer steps actually
um okay so what happens oh look suddenly
it's much much better
um uh maybe not surprisingly this is
only with batch size five
yeah really small batch size takes what
looked like garbage before basically
from anyone who wanted to implement this
into to use this until like yeah now
it's fine yeah it's like actually
really good um like maybe i could also
have made
taken epsilon equal to five that maybe
that would have helped but
uh this synthetic one i think this is
actually 20
i think 20 right 10 10 or 20. i can't
remember actually for this one
yeah yeah not super high and for mnist
we've projected down
uh 50 right or so
um and same with i think kdd cup so yeah
this is lower
not not super high dimension so um same
thing happens for kde cup also we only
need batch size five and
for mnist which was batch size 10 and
now it's like
there you go they're both started in a
good place they're both very happy right
and
maybe i should have plotted this on a
log scale so you could see anything so
moral is mini batching helps a lot small
mini batching helps a lot right
okay good okay what about the best batch
size now now that we know that it helps
so we should now
ask harder questions what's the what's
the best batch size
uh okay well it looks like um from the
synthetic data experiment
it looks like oh i should just keep
choosing larger and larger batch size
which seems a little odd to me
seems to hold in this other data set
this is for step size one over t
uh and also for mnist so now so now the
message is okay bigger batches are good
in fact take as
large batches as you possibly can
subject to your computational
constraints right and then that seems a
bit suspicious
so maybe you should step back and say
okay what else is going on but
it's not actually true i mean it'd
hockey stick up at some point
so going back to the synthetic data so
now this is what step size 100 over t
um
if you change it to one over root t then
you're being a bit
uh less aggressive in your in your steps
and when you're less aggressive in your
steps actually taking very large batch
size starts to hurt you
um and so the point is that you get a
you do get a knee and you get a knee
kind of around five
in this case um also around
well yeah around five and ktd cup or ten
you get a similar kind of knee and you
so you see
here um is that uh bigger batches are
good for aggressive step sizes like one
over t
and then optimal batch size uh you there
is a sort of optimal batch size for for
more conservative step sizes and so
there's a
relationship between these two things
which we don't quite understand
theoretically but uh
clearly is appearing empirically yeah
did you try
adapt like adapting the step size having
the batch size change over time
no we didn't try that but that's another
thing that that you could do as well
yeah it's just there's like a lot of
like i said there's a lot of knobs so
that that might that might in fact have
a very good empirical performance for
all i know like because then you would
tune essentially tune the noise to the
step size
right so you might imagine that those
first steps having accurate you know
those first steps where you're traveling
far yeah you want to be more accurate
right yeah and then you can just kind of
wiggle around with small step size at
the end
so uh okay so there are many many and
now that i'm i'm
i'm bad time i think um there are many
many interesting questions uh many
so there's like how should we set all of
these knobs there's other knobs to
choose besides the step size and the
batch size
you can try averaging you could try it
um so
the one question is what what gains are
there if i don't demand continuous
observation what if i don't have to
publish the iterates of my grading to
send algorithm then maybe i should be
able to do
maybe you should do better i mean
hopefully you should do better um
uh the question we were motivated in
this
but you know the reason we're looking at
this is we're motivated by problems at
essentially looking at multiple sources
of data with different privacy
constraints and therefore
you sort of have to process them in some
order the question is what order
should you process them in um there's
obviously connections to online gradient
learning algorithms um
as well as uh and also algorithms like
mirror descent which is a different way
of solving the same problem
so it should be um interesting ways of
uh working on that as well and also just
in general these kind of stochastic what
about stochastic optimization versions
of other algorithms like the power
iteration maybe there's a sort of a
single point version of that that could
also
be benefit from because those kind of
things also appear in
a lot of machine learning applications
so thank you and
happy to take any questions
the stochastic rating descent will
perform exactly in terms of samples
but this is i'm not so here i'm not
actually interested in the sample
complexity i want to know what the i
mean so sample complexity is fine
all a lot of gradient descent procedures
you have two gradient center procedures
and they work
both have like you know one over t
convergence
uh to the optimum but then one of them
will actually turn out to be
much better than the other one so yeah
it's true i agree yeah i mean
so being exactly sample complexity
optimal
is uh is a good thing
but it's certainly not what we're
looking at here
currently i think there's a tighter
error convergence rate for the averaging
algorithm
oh for playing computer general under oh
right because that yeah those are recent
archives
right actually working on that okay cool
i'd love to know more yeah so your
algorithms end up touching
much less than the whole data set right
like on a lot of these experiments here
so again for endness actually i think we
ended up processing we're not we're not
doing one versus we no we're doing one
with some digit versus all versus the
rest rate so they're in like the data
so you mean in the plots yeah uh yeah
for some of the data for some of the
algorithms we don't we don't end up
touching all the data so
you could use that to get us to change
your epsilons
so say just the fact that you you're oh
i can change my epsilons at every every
step yeah
no what i meant is that because your
substance because you're
only working with a subsample of the
data that sort of amplifies your epsilon
if the total curve
is
you're saying if if you're going to you
know if the the number of iterations and
the
relative relative yeah relative to the
number of batches the size of the
batches is such that so you only touch
you know five percent of your data yeah
but it's much more than five percent
that we're touching right so okay
yeah i guess that was my yeah yeah it's
not like it's not like uh
um it's not like constant fraction where
you know epsilon just some small epsilon
greater than zero the data that we're
touching we're touching like you know
more than half of them
that would buy you now it might not buy
you a ton but
but it could buy you in in the very very
large data set setting it could buy you
quite a bit actually so in general if
you sample a p
fraction basically improves epsilon by p
sure no we could
yes because i'm not telling you which
data points i'm touching right right